there's a lot in the news today and we
are not going to talk about any of it
because who cares it's something about a
memo lying Democrat same story different
day instead we will analyze feminism
right down to its cold frigid bra
burning core with PJ Media columnist and
Disney Princess enthusiast faith more
one question which is the greater
fiction snow white or feminism then the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
I am so excited to get to this today we
actually we dug deep into the daily wire
archives we found some incredible
historical footage of what women were
like before feminism and and then also
obviously what women are like after
feminism we have to talk about all of it
we have a wonderful thinker and writer
on the show today before we get to any
event that we have to talk about shaving
we have to this is something you know
maybe I'll read a book or I'll think
about some important idea it once a week
once every seven weeks something like
that but I shave every single day so
you've heard me talk of the amazing
shave I get from my Dollar Shave Club
razor especially when I use it with
there dr. Carver's shaved butter well I
am here to tell you that I'm never
giving up my membership in fact I'm
adding even more DSC products to my
daily routine Dollar Shave Club makes
products for your hair face skin shower
everything you need it is the best razor
I've ever used and I actually buy nice
razors this is so good they have me
looking and feeling great it's all of
their own original stuff they use only
the finest premium ingredients and they
deliver it to you so it's just like with
all of the the razors they started out
with razors and instead of having to go
to the pharmacy and up and down the
aisle and then you know you go into that
aisle that men aren't supposed to go
into and you feel very weird and creepy
and you look around no one saw I mean
you don't forget about any of that stuff
you can get be like a normal person in
the 21st century and you can order this
online you'll come right to your door
it's very inexpensive there are no more
annoying trips to the store I use Dollar
Shave Club for almost everything razors
body cleanser hair gels they even have
this new product which guys so in Europe
you know Europeans are they're very
interested in being clean everywhere not
just like we rugged Americans who are
clean most places so they have an
invention called a bidet and it allows
you to clean where the Sun don't shine
well in America if you don't want to
have a giant bidet installed in your
house that's a very expensive sort of
thing you probably have to go to the
store for that and pick it out you can
just use wipes for your derriere that
come to you from Dollar Shave Club
they're very effective so I'm told now
it is a great time to give Dollar Shave
Club
try you can get your first month of
their best razor and it's a really
really good razor along with travel
sized versions of shave butter body
cleanser and yes even that derriere
cleaner for just $5 this is basically
free if you have ever bought an even
sort of nice razor if you even bought a
bag of those terrible little disposable
ones it's more than $5 so just get this
it's basically free after that
replacement cartridges ship for just a
few bucks a month
it is the DSC starter kit get yours for
just $5 exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa co v
fe fe that is dollarshaveclub.com slash
cough fa what is it Marshall Dollar
Shave Club comm slash cough FA okay
excellent now we talk about history a
lot on the show you know that so
consider this a mini this day in history
segment because the archivists at the
daily wire have dug up incredible
footage showing what women used to look
like before
feminism let's see it
[Music]
I'm sorry I didn't mean to fight but you
don't know what I've been through and
all because I was afraid I'm so ashamed
ah chirp chirp chirp that was so nice
that was like watching a cartoon sweet
little ELISA
so we Lily says very fair-skinned it was
just like what a beautiful and now also
I'm sorry you had to come out of it
now let's take a look at what feminism
has turned women into
male that doesn't stand for women's
rights
I get that camera out of my face see
what I am the feminist who is out to
ruin your life I am the feminist who is
ruining your perfectly respectful
marriage by suggesting Audrey Lorde to
the book club
that your wife attends and yes I am the
one who convinced her to get that
shorter haircut did you pretend to like
but don't really like I am the feminist
who is pushing your daughter down the
slippery slope of hood by giving
her a high five when she says she keeps
her own supply of condoms and
incidentally I've tried to turn her
bisexual gay by recommending some dental
dam
yes that's progress there it is there's
the progress everybody what an
advancement how enlightened now we are
what wonderful things feminism has
brought to the world we have to bring on
now faith more a wonderful writer about
all things feminist and more importantly
a Disney princess addict faith thank you
for coming on hi thanks for having me
it's great to be here so faith my first
question which is more of a fantasy
Disney or feminism feminism is based on
a lie it's based on the lie that men and
women are the same that gender is a
social contract that's a lie Disney
tells the truth about women and what's
so strange about it too is that is the
central line men and women are the same
they're indistinguishable and yet it's
called feminism they always say well it
just means men and women they deserve
the same rights or whatever but then why
is it called feminism it's that we have
a philosophy for that which is called
egalitarianism so it seems on the one
hand it says men and women are exactly
the same and on the other hand women are
this totally separate categorical entity
and we need to give them everything and
let
them yell at us and kick our signs down
well not only that it also ends up
saying that men are actually better than
women because if you say that gender is
a social construct and men and women are
exactly the same but everything that is
feminine is because of the oppression of
men so women have to act more like men
that means men are better than women
everything within the category of woman
is lesser and worse and terrible given
that given and it's funny because given
the premise if men and women really are
no different then there are no women
right then there isn't a categorical
distinction between men and women it's
just it's just men and men with long
hair who look nicer now faith you love
Disney Princesses you have a pretty big
Facebook page about this you write about
this frequently why do you love them so
I love Disney Princesses well all girls
love Disney Princesses I mean little
girls love Disney Princesses that's the
most controversial statement that has
ever been uttered on my program yeah I'm
here to see you just really shake things
up with my Disney princess conversation
no I mean it doesn't matter how much
feminists try to convince us that little
girls don't love princesses they do they
love princesses and the thing about
Disney Princesses is that they're
actually a great they're great role
models for modern girls because they're
they're brave and passionate and
outspoken and they have goals and they
follow their dreams and all these things
but they do it without compromising
their femininity their kindness their
nurturing nature they want love they
want to start a family all of these
things but somewhere along the line
feminists got a hold of the narrative
about Disney Princesses and they did to
the princesses what they do to women
which is that because they act like
women they've decided that they're just
these victim damsels in distress'
husband hunters and we believe them so
the the pub the general public sort of
believes them so anyone who tells you
that they love Disney Princesses
apologizes first they say like I know I
know they're really I'm sorry mom I'm
sorry but I just really love them you
know and and moms like they banned them
from their houses
they're not allowed to like their
daughters I'm allowed to watch some of
these things but but really I think in
our current culture and our current
situation situation about gender these
are some really great stories for little
girls to be looking at to figure out how
to become women and you make the point
on damsels in distress that's that's how
a lot of people think of them that's how
they portrayed that they're just waiting
for the man to come around but you say
they're not damsels in distress just
like women before feminism weren't just
helpless damsels in distress what do
these people get wrong so I mean you
just play that whole thing about Snow
White and in fact in that clip that you
played she says I'm so what did she say
I'm so ashamed of the fuss I've made and
so when you think about that right this
is a person who I mean in that scene
she's just been like someone threatened
to kill her essentially and then she ran
away and she can never come home so
that's bad and but she's so ashamed of
the fuss that she's made right and the
next thing that she does is she goes to
a house find that it would be a really
good place to hide out
and decides to make a deal with the
people who live there she is gonna cook
and clean for them because she knows how
to do that and they'll let her stay so I
mean if if feminists want her to be a
freeloader and just get the men in the
house to take care of her then that
would be fine I guess but really what
she does is she actually shows up with a
plan that's right she's not just
offering her body or something she says
I have these skills and I'm gonna make a
deal and strike out on my own and not
have to become some fake man in order to
do it exactly and I think they're
they're almost all like that until you
get to the princesses that are the more
recent ones that are supposed to be more
modern and then you get these princesses
who are sort of like infantilized and
objectified like in their own story
except those are the ones because they
write and that's the new fiction that
they're it were it's not that we're
seeing this throughout all of these
Disney movies and more largely
throughout all of the folk tales and
fables that come
us through the tradition it were
actually this is a modern advancement
that the women are oppressed that there
this is an ideological vision that's
being imposed even on these stories even
on these Disney stories how long until
we see a transgender Disney Princess oh
it's it's coming there's no development
right now yeah I think so I mean we had
the first boy princess but it was it was
in a cartoon on television so like I
said it doesn't officially count but
yeah I mean there was a boy who was
dressing up as a girl in order to do
something or other and you know so he
was sort of lauded as Disney's first boy
princess oh my gosh I actually don't
follow the you'll be shocked to hear
this I don't follow Disney very closely
I didn't so that they're already testing
into what will become inevitably the
transgender Disney Princess also known
as the end of Disney Princesses right
exactly yeah I mean I think that's
probably that's really gonna happen I
mean there's already called for Elsa
from frozen to be a lesbian since you
know she didn't have a love interest in
all of this stuff so I mean all of that
all of that is coming and I think you're
just gonna lose the girls you know
you're right then but this is when this
is what happens in the culture generally
they loot they insist on adding this
ideological vision and then they lose
their audience because it's no longer
entertaining it no longer corresponds to
reality as we know reality is we as we
as we see ourselves and as we see other
people in the world and they lose all
the audience but they still win all of
the awards because it's so important man
isn't it so important and powerful right
exactly you know and and now we're
essentially telling you know my least
favorite Disney movie of all Disney
princess movie of all time
is brave and brave is a story about not
growing up because they can't they can't
have her find a husband that they can't
have her you know have her life they
have basically she goes out on the whole
quest that a Disney Princess goes out on
and then ends up right back home where
she started and we have no idea what's
gonna happen to her so that's that's
essentially what's happening is they're
infantilizing women by making it so that
they can't they can't leave home because
there's nothing for them out there
that's right you knew you know there
there is Peter Pan but Peter Pan is a
sad tale it's a sad thing that Peter
can't grow up and doesn't move on with
his life
and I think this is sort of a tease
right exactly I think this is kind of a
rationalist this is what happens with
ideologies ideology forgets that we live
in time and we live in space and so they
say this is it this is the frozen moment
but I don't know I really liked college
college was a lot of fun I don't wish
that I were still in college because
that's in the past I like other you know
I've it was fun to be a child that I
don't wish that I were still a child and
they lose that and and all conservatives
I like to think look at reality as it is
and they understand that we live in time
we live in a space and you can't stay
and never Neverland forever Lefty's tell
us they tell us all the time that gender
is a social construct but I'm looking at
you faith you look very much like a lady
you seem objectively prettier than I am
your voice is higher pitched than mine
is is there evidence that gender is a
social construct no in fact I think
there's evidence that it is not a social
construct that it is inherent in men to
be men and women to be women and there
are even there are studies that sort of
you know the most recent one I saw was
about sort of toy preference and they
kind of they've they weeded out all of
these things like you know whether the
mom and dad were there and all of this
stuff and it was like the girls picked
the girl toys the boy I mean no it's
ridiculous you know I and I think that
when when you try to prove that that
gender is a social construct you you end
up just sort of talking yourself in
circles and when the feminists do it
they end up talking themselves into
victimhood essentially no of course they
it always ironically something that's
supposed to empower them ends up making
them like little children and I love
that you brought up the scientific
studies because I've seen these two
studies that show that regardless of
socialization regardless of the awful
patriarchal culture boys want to play
with boy toys and robot girls won't play
with girl toys and then in fake studies
in like gender studies one of my hobbies
a few years ago a buddy of mine did
and I we did we did this on tumblr we
created a blog called Gender Studies
department and as always I think it's
still up there Gender Studies department
- blog tumblr comm and we would just
post quotes from actual peer-reviewed
published Gender Studies papers that
absolutely meant nothing they were just
random words
and so one quote says and this is by
this might be the most rational quote of
all of them it says at the root of
ecofeminism is the understanding that
the many systems of oppression are
mutually reinforcing building on the
socialist feminist insight that racism
classism and sexism are interconnected
eco feminists whatever that is
recognized additional similarities
between those forms of human oppression
and the oppressive structures of
speciesism and naturism and ism ISM and
ISM ISM ISM I notice all of these other
lefty ideas socialism environmentalism
they keep creeping into discussions
about feminism can there be a
conservative feminism I sometimes hear
some of my conservative or my
conservative ish female friends say
things like you know a woman with a gun
that yeah with a gun that's real
feminism or a woman CEO raising children
and go and work every day that's
feminism or whatever they say is there a
conservative feminism or are isms and
ideologies like feminism just
incompatible with with conservative
thought well I think that at the heart
of feminism or I guess at the beginning
of feminism I think it began with a
notion that we can all agree with which
is that men and women are equally
valuable to society that that you need
men and women and that you know women
should be allowed to do the same kinds
of things as men if they want to do them
and I think and so I think that if that
were still true about feminism then
maybe we could get behind it
more than then we can now but that that
isn't actually what the feminists now
are saying you know they're not they're
not saying it's that men and women are
equally valuable to society they're
saying
that they're the same and that certain
traits be they male or female are
positive or negative I mean the thing is
men have inherently male traits and
women have inherently female traits and
there's no moral judgement about that it
just is mm-hmm
so when you start to put moral judgment
on the inherent traits that's when you
get lost and I think that feminism has
gotten lost so I don't I don't know what
the word would be for someone who thinks
rationally but Christian you know so yes
there are some other versions too
rational people yeah I don't know that
you know that that's absolutely right
there's a the complementarity of the
sexes poses equal value in christianity
and judaism the eve is plucked out of
Adam's rib not out of his head she's not
higher than Adam out of his foot she's
not lower than a time right out of his
rib in the beginning God created man
both male and female he created them
they've equal dignity but they're
clearly not the same I hope they're not
the same the blogger speaking speaking
of the complementarity of the sexes
we're gonna get a little saucy here
the bloggers Samara over at scary mommy
wrote a piece called sometimes I want to
be held by a man naked without having
sex is that okay the answer is no by the
way she says that women need intimacy in
their lives and therefore they should be
able to expect it from randos that they
hook up with what is wrong with that
can't women have it all no actually
women can't have it all even when they
say when they're referring to the other
thing which is like working and raising
kids they can't have it all in that area
either but um no that is a ridiculous
request because and the reason it's a
ridiculous request is because you don't
actually know that person and therefore
you can't have intimacy with him you can
have an intimate act but you can't have
anything yet intimate as in like get it
on as in like you know whatever you want
to call that but you can't have intimacy
with that person because you just met
them like an hour ago
and you know now you're upstairs in
their apartment naked and and I think
you know like if if you get naked in
front of someone that
just met um I think you're basically
sending the message that you would like
to have sex you're not really sending
the message that you'd like to just kind
of lie there and I don't always the
message I'm trying to send I don't know
if people are misinterpreting what I'm
that's the message you know one time I
went on a date with his ease I'm sorry
and he and I he and I just had clicked
well I'll save it for another time
but we just had very different views of
what was happening you know well if
you'd like to tell me I can publish it
and I'll keep your name and all good
keep it anonymous I hope not a lot of
people watch the show so I don't think
it'll really get out you know yes that
is that is so right there there is
because you you wrote beautifully on
this topic about how women do long for
these things in a way that men don't I
don't want to tell any tales at a school
here folks but it turns out that men are
more comfortable with casual sex and
desire it more than women do broadly
speaking now do you think that me too
speaking of is awful me too
some center-right writers have jumped on
board though they say yes these awful
men they've harassed me too
what is wrong with this slacked abyss de
jour yeah me too has sort of devolved
into this I mean it's something really
interesting I think is happening about
me too which is that you know initially
it arose I guess because of all of the
really horrible things that were going
on like Harvey Weinstein and all of
those other people and and people were
saying you know I was really really
truly violated and but it was very it
very quickly devolved into yes you know
me too because somebody can't called me
on the street or you know me too because
I saw a man one time or me too just
because my Michael knows looks you just
kind of laying out an Italian you got a
gold chain it's doesn't I don't think
like that guy on the subway looked like
he was going to ask for my number and
did it me too so yeah you know it's kind
of that really deal Ajith amaizing the
victims of actual sexual Christ
right like lumping all of those things
together is really a terrible thing to
do to people that have actually
experienced something horrific but
especially these
days there's great currency in
victimhood this whole my mother was more
floors for less money thing
and so you see rape hoaxes you see a
spike in rape Oakes's on campus both
before college and and obviously on
college campuses we've had major I the
the the vast majority if not all of the
major headline-grabbing rape cases at
universities in the last five years have
come out to be hoaxes beginning with
Duke Lacrosse but all the way up to the
UVA scandal
that Rolling Stone breathlessly reported
on without any evidence there's a lot of
currency in that in that victimhood it
seems to say something about the culture
that we're so proud to be victims it
seems that something is unhealthy in the
culture yeah absolutely and I think I
think that it's all sort of a product of
this you know we're we're so oppressed
you know gender social constructs kind
of mentality because if women are
supposed to behave like men when it
comes to sex and they're supposed to
want to have the kinds of meaningless
sex and you know like swipe in whatever
direction on tinder they're supposed to
be swiping you know then then it's
always the fault of the man if they feel
violated right where they feel
uncomfortable in some way because that
wasn't actually what they wanted to do
what they wanted to do was meet a nice
guy and fall in love and you know get
married have children so you know then
but it allows you to maintain the lie by
saying that you're the victim you were
victimized something went wrong this
isn't normally how this progresses this
regret is so I'm supposed to behave I'm
supposed to want this but you know so
you did something wrong and I'm the
victim and now we can maintain the lie
right
that's absolutely right you are happily
married so you haven't fallen victim to
this awful trap you're a stay-at-home
mother and you're married in the
old-fashioned way this is you're married
in the very old-school way
where you find another person and then
join with them together but that's
because you're not hip enough for
szilágyi me
you've heard of salami in 2006 Alexandre
Gill
married herself she had a ceremony for
herself an Italian woman last year Laura
Maisy invited 70 guests to a farmhouse
in Bimmer caught a to marry herself a 38
year old British woman named Sophie
Tanner in 2015 married herself after her
father Shane she cheated on herself and
that was after her father had given her
away to herself so sad the wedding party
and hers by the way then danced to
kendrick lamar's I love myself Sex in
the City mentioned it in 2003 a lead
character on Glee in 2010 enjoyed a
Salah gomess ceremony is this the most
depressing thing ever or is this a force
is this is this the perfectly logical
conclusion of feminism yeah I mean I
it's all of the above really depressing
and a farce
I think I mean I mean they certainly
don't think it's a farce they believe
everything that they're saying but yeah
I mean I don't even know what that means
to marry yourself I mean aren't you
already married to your Simon like can
you separate from yourself because if
you if you can't separate from yourself
then you can't marry yourself either I
don't I don't think you can even
procreate with yourself try try as I
have I don't think it's possible it
seems like it's slapping lipstick on a
pig to use a phrase because you pee
these people are alone and it's sad that
they're alone and it would be nice
probably if they found somebody and
probably they could find somebody but
rather than say gosh I'm alone and maybe
I should change that and somewhere I
should do something to change that
instead what they do is they say it's
good to feel alone yeah I don't feel
terrible I feel great about it and it's
really sad a kind of related question I
guess as we're talking about these
traditionalism versus modernism should
women stay home to raise their children
did you make the right decision I
definitely made the right decision for
me I mean I there is nothing i could
imagine doing other than this and I
think that more women probably should do
it then and do now but I really I had
to say every woman should do something
because then I start to sound like the
feminist you know so I think what I
definitely think is that you this this
thing you can have it all you know you
can work and you can have your kid
that's not true right if you if you go
to work then you're making a decision to
parent less and to work less right you
have you have to there has to be a
give-and-take everywhere so it's a
decision that you're making but you have
to know that that's the decision that
you're making it's not hooray I'm gonna
be you know a stay-at-home mom at the
same time as being at the office all
decisions closed off other opportunities
to make one decision is to say no to
many other ones you know speaking of
decision making Chesterton said that
heresy isn't the promotion of Vice over
virtue it's the promotion of one virtue
to the exclusion of all of the others
that today seems to be consent
you know most bars and nightclubs now
employ a notary public so they can stamp
your physical contact consent forms in
every single drunken encounter after I
think light hand stuff I think that's
the point at which you have to go to the
notary he will stamp it then you can
walk out together I haven't read the
statutes in a while why does our culture
elevated consent to be more important
than anything else because we've
elevated sex to be more important than
anything else
so when when you know well the person
that you are about to engage in sexual
activity with it's ridiculous to assume
that you should have consider it incants
a person who knows you that you know
them if if something is happening that
one of you doesn't like you can't just
say so
I mean that's fine I mean you probably
should have written consent if you
decide to have sex with someone you just
met at a bar I mean who who knows like
what does who this person is and what
they're into I mean you don't know you
know it could be Marshall from goodness
sakes you don't know who you're gonna
meet you've only talked to the person
for an hour exactly I hear a little um
yeah so I mean I think that's the
problem right we we've said that that
the
is more important than the connection or
the intimacy or you know love and so
then we don't actually know what we're
getting it's ironic to it what's ironic
in the sense that sex is
we're told the sexist meaningless it's
casual you can do it whenever you want
it's just like shaking a hand and but
also it's the most important thing ever
so if it's just casual if sex is no that
doesn't carry any moral weight then
sexual assault is no worse than slapping
somebody in the face right because the
sexual part doesn't make it any worse or
more grave or more serious but of course
we know that isn't that isn't true and
on this as we're as we're going back in
time we go to Chesterton we can go back
to Burke Burke wrote about the age of
ideologies revolution France proto
feminism he said is so prescient in
every way he wrote now all is to be
changed all the pleasing illusions which
made power gentle independence liberal
which harmonized the different shades of
life and which by a bland assimilation
incorporated into politics the
sentiments which beautify and soften
private society are to be dissolved by
this new conquering Empire of light and
reason all the decent drapery of life is
to be rudely torn off all the superadded
ideas furnished from a wardrobe of a
moral imagination which the heart owns
and the understanding ratifies as a
necessary to cover the defects of our
naked shivering nature and to raise it
to dignity in our own estimation are to
be exploded as a ridiculous absurd and
antiquated fashion on this scheme of
things a king is but a man a queen is
but a woman a woman is but an animal and
an animal not of the highest order and
vomit all on edge paid to the sex in
general as such and without distinct
views is to be regarded as romance and
folly regicide and parasite and
sacrilege but the fictions of
superstition corrupting jurisprudence by
destroying its simplicity this feminism
ultimately mean that a woman is but an
animal and an animal not of the highest
order
gosh well I lost you a little bit in the
feet so I didn't know of what you just
said but I heard the end of it I
I don't know how to answer that I feel
like I feel like feminism
I mean in
and I don't think it turns them into
brutes like you know cows or something a
doesn't throw them into angry bulls he
although but looking at that first video
perhaps the it's an open question but it
doesn't I don't think he means that I
think he means it takes away all of the
things that elevate us above our animal
nature does it to men to actually turns
us into just brutes who have no sense of
chivalry and because they also don't see
any femininity in front of them nothing
to elevate men out of our maybe
knuckle-dragging beast like nature but
faith your honor they do that to us
you're enough to elevate this whole show
have we ever had a more elevated show
than this usually it's just like me and
flexed marks or something is absolutely
in the gutter faith thank you for being
here we have to move on to the mailbag
so nice to see you I
you wouldn't you are so lovely and nice
and articulate you would never know that
you're Andrew Slavens daughter
you would never it's a thank you faith
thank you for being let's move on to the
mailbag oh my gosh Marshall you monster
you all right fine we have to talk first
oh we get to talk about upside this is
pretty good
how are your things to do in 2018 coming
along mine is a work in progress and you
can read that as I've abandoned all of
them but there's there's one thing that
should there's maybe there are a couple
I'm still keeping around one thing that
you should know if you travel for
business
I travel a bit for business you need you
know business travel is awful to book it
it's awful if you have to change your
flight or this or that it becomes a huge
headache and becomes very expensive and
you frequently don't get great great
accommodations and great travel book
your next business trip on upside calm
when you do you will get the better
business travel experience you deserve
and a free pair of Bose Soundlink
wireless headphones more on that in a
second first here's why you love upside
it has great customer service
specialists who will look out for you
every step of the trip they will handle
any problem that might pop up usually
I'll just call sweet little Alisa and
weeping and have her talk to the credit
card company in the flight and of this
and spare your friends and loved ones
and co-workers all of that headache
just use up side the the team is hard at
work 24/7 to make sure your flight hotel
and rental car all go off without a
hitch they're available on demand by
chat phone and email whenever you need
them
only up side monitors your business trip
around the clock proactively keeping you
posted on everything from the weather in
the city you're going to to changing
your flight home so you can just adjust
your meeting schedule I kid you not one
time I was in the UK and my airline just
decided that my return ticket wasn't
valid anymore and they didn't tell me
about this I didn't hear about this
until 15 hours before my flight back
across the world direct to Los Angeles
and that was a very frustrating and
expensive experience so don't let that
happen to you plus upside has great
prices for flights hotels and rental
cars now to get your free pair of Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones just
booked your first business trip with up
side by going to up side comm slash
cough FA Co V Fe Fe that is upside comm
slash cough FA to claim your Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones upside
comm you deserve a better business trip
headphones are available while supplies
last must be first up side purchase $600
minimum purchase required
si side for complete details the lawyers
make you say that kind of thing but go
to up side comm / Co V Fe Fe okay let's
get into the mailbag we're running late
we got a hurry Scott Marshall stop it
man why don't you let these people get
one mailbag question okay I'm sorry
we have got to sign off if you're on
Facebook in YouTube you have to go to
daily wire com you're probably not on
YouTube because they keep censoring us
because they're colluding with CNN so
whenever we use a feed from c-span which
is owned by the government you and I pay
for it in our tax dollars CNN will come
in and issue a copyright claim because
they want to shut us down because our
live stream had five times as many
viewers as CNN's ridiculous fake news
live stream and YouTube was happy to
accommodate and they shut down our
channel so you know probably you're not
watching on YouTube if you're watching
on Facebook go over to daily wire.com
what do you get you get me the Andrew
Clavin show the ben shapiro show the
conversation i'm the next one up baby
it's gonna be the day before Valentine's
Day so ask me all of your love questions
but forget all that none of that matters
what really matters is the leftist tears
tumblr we listen we have just watched
all of those screaming shrieking
feminists at the beginning of the show
you're gonna need this otherwise you're
gonna be not only will your ears be
out by their awful myung screams but
also you will drown in their in their
lefty tears so make sure you go to Delhi
um we'll be right back
let's get right into it first question
from Ashton